to have the chief exec of the nhs
confederation uh with us now and that is
matthew taylor hello to you mr taylor
thank you for joining us this morning
i'm sure you heard what the minister
said today saying we don't need the plan
b at the moment no more lockdowns what
we need is people to take up their
boosters and vaccinations
so the government said that the criteria
for determining whether or not we
enacted elements of plan b was the
position of the health service
and the health service is facing a
perfect storm it's the combination of
three things it is the fact that winter
is always tough for the health service
for various reasons
it's the fact that we have got thousands
of kobe patients in hospital and it
looks like those numbers are rising in
line with the rising infection rate
and we've also got the huge demand
pent-up demand that's built up over the
last 18 months not just people on
waiting lists if you haven't been to see
the doctor some of whom are now
presented with quite challenging
symptoms so the health service is
working incredibly hard and has managed
to get many services back on track and
even to chip away at those waiting lists
but every health service leader i speak
to says that they are right at the edge
and we're already missing important
targets missing targets on waiting times
in emergency departments missing
ambulance response targets missing
targets on waiting lists and that's the
situation now in the middle of october
so we we know that things are almost
inevitably going to get worse and the
question is simply this do we accept
some inconveniences the inconveniences
of plan b and do we recognize as a
nation we need to get behind our health
and care system over the next months or
do we somehow cross our fingers and hope
that the almost inevitable doesn't
happen and stumbled into a crisis
the minister i did push him on that sir
and the minister uh say it's just not
helpful to talk about restrictions we
need to get the economy uh back on track
again and all these talk of of
restrictions and potential lockdowns
it's not going to happen
well the question is
do we need to act and i would say the
overwhelming evidence is that we do need
to act and then the question is is it
better to act early
and take measures which don't stop the
economy
working but i recognize they are
inconvenient for people
or do we wait
wait for things to get worse and
possibly risk having to take more severe
measures
so the elements of plan b enable us to
carry on with our lives to carry on with
the economy but to do it in a way which
reduces the risk and after all
most of the measures in plan b are
measures that other countries in europe
are continuing to enact and they have
lower infection rates than we do
but the difference the minister was
saying is the vaccination program we
didn't have the vaccination program this
time last year and although we can see
people um are getting kovi perhaps for
the second time they're not it's not as
severe then and not as many people
are dying
from covid as we saw at the beginning of
the year
yes but as you've just discussed we have
the issue of waning immunity we don't
know exactly what's going on but it does
look as part of what's driving more
cases and then further down the line
what more hospitalization is that away
in the immunity it is absolutely vital
that people take up the opportunity of
the booster jabs and get a flu jab in
fact what we're saying today is not just
plan b but plan b plus and the plus bit
is that we as the public need to do
things which will make things better for
the health service that's taking up
these vaccinations it's using the health
service responsibly it's supporting
health and care staff as we did during
wave one and wave two of kovid so it's
absolutely vital we do that but the
reality is those numbers
uh are rising they're continuing uh to
rise and that's why we need to act now
because the effect of acting now will
not be felt for a few weeks but if we
don't act now
already we're in a situation where it is
likely that in two or three weeks things
are going to be worse so that's why we
need to act uh immediately but it sounds
like you're on the same page as the
government that's you're saying the same
thing make sure that you get your
booster or make sure that the kids get
vaccinated and things will be okay
no because that will take time and in
the time that it is taking us to get
those boosters and we all hope that you
know by the point of next spring
we're in a position where most people or
who need the booster vaccine have had it
and that we are able to get things back
on track but over the next few months
while that vaccine is rolling out the
numbers are continuing to rise and
that's why we need to take action to
reduce the spread of the virus we've got
a very particular problem over this
winter and we need to act
you sound very frustrated um by um the i
suppose um in action you might use that
word of the government just how bad do
you think things are going to get in in
the next few weeks unless um they
activate plan b plus
i think what's frustrating is that the
government has said that it is the
pressure on the health service that will
be the determinant of whether or not
they act
i speak to health leaders every day in
every part of the service ambulance
services mental health services the
acute sector i haven't spoken to a
single one who doesn't say that they are
incredibly stretched we are already
missing by significant margin our
targets on waiting times emergency
departments waiting times for ambulance
of course the waiting lists themselves
so we're missing those targets now and
that has an impact on patient safety
and it's only going to get worse so the
government needs to
it needs to act on its promise and its
promises to try to protect the nhs from
becoming overwhelmed and that's where we
need to act now in order to head off
that and if we don't
i'm afraid we will once again and we
have been here before we will stumble
into a crisis
so what does plan b plus look like for
you what do you want to see happen
so there's plan b which is
the measures the government has talked
about which is requiring people to wear
masks in crowded places
discouraging unnecessary indoor uh
gatherings working from home if you can
the plus part
is the way in which we use the health
service when we looked at when covert
first wave happened we were out
applauding the health service on a
thursday evening now i'm sadly hearing
of gps who are being abused by patients
because they aren't getting the service
that they want because those gps are
overwhelmed or are only able to offer
initially a digital consultation for
example so getting behind the health
service
and also there are other things that we
can do we absolutely as i said we can
get the jobs that we need to have but
also look out for our neighbors there's
more news today about shortages in
social care now social care is outside
the nhs but if people are not getting
their social care visit during the day
they are more likely to end up needing
an ambulance so if there are people in
your community who you know are
vulnerable you know i check in on them
because they may not bidding that social
care visit because there are parts of
our social care system where you've got
vacancy rates of 10 15
okay so you want people to be wearing
masks in public places
do you want travel restrictions people
not going overseas on holiday perhaps
the return of the red list um and do you
want kids to still be going to school
just explain to me more detail what it
is that you're looking for that the
government is not doing at the moment
but it's the responsibility of the
government and its scientific advisors
to work through what exactly is needed i
don't think the measures you've just
described closing schools or banning
international travel
are necessary at this stage and that's
part of the argument if we can do those
things which are inconvenient but allow
life to go on
then we may not have to do things which
which will have a bigger impact uh you
know i use the london underground quite
a lot and i have noticed that there are
fewer people wearing masks on
underground
in the underground i've also noticed
that you know if you're in a carriage
where most people are home masks those
who aren't kind of that they clock it
and they put their masks on but when
you're in a carriage where half the
people aren't then there isn't any
pressure so we we need to support each
other and the government needs to
support us in doing those things which
may be an inconvenience but which do
make a difference and so if you can work
from home
though is it sir i mean that's that's
down to our own responsibility i mean
you have it's a legal requirement to
wear your mask on the underground if
people don't do it there's not much the
government can do about that it's about
our own personal responsibility isn't it
well it is but government plays an
important role in shaping the national
conversation and i think that's why
we're calling this plan b plus because
we're we're calling on the government to
to urge a national mobilization behind
our health and care system to recognize
the inevitability of an incredibly
difficult few months ahead and to be
give a very clear message to the public
and that does make a difference so yes
we should all take responsibility but
when we if we've heard the government
say look this is the crisis that we're
facing you do need to act then you know
it reminds us and it
emboldens us to say to the person
sitting exhausted on the tube you forgot
on your mask or to say to our employer
look actually i can do this from home so
government messaging does help each of
us to do the right thing
just before i let you go uh mr taylor
the uh one of the other vaccines
available or potentially available soon
would be val neva do you know about that
vaccine tell us about why that we're not
using that at the moment
uh i know i don't know about that um
look the important thing is the
availability of vaccines overall and
what i don't want people to feel
is that in a sense they're not able to
get vaccinations if you are in the
category that is supposed to be getting
a booster jab or getting a flu jab then
you know it is there the services are
available and you need to go out and get
it
okay good to talk to you thanks for
joining us on the program this morning
thank you